we're gonna see how much you know about
this week's pop culture so this week's
iPhone 8 and X were revealed am I gonna
buy it hell to the no so it's 999
dollars and you have the choice you can
either do like the X or you can do the 8
I love when people put an X there like
it's cool like hell no it still cost
$1000 the way that I would be so okay
with a flip phone they're asking you to
spend $1000 but there's still no
software to stop you from texting your
mother-fucking X this entire phone is so
extra I'm nervous if I got it and I did
the facial recognition like there's like
Kirsten like awakened with makeup on and
then there's person in her house eating
noodles out of a cup they have like a
little bit of water resistance but I
want like the full-blown water proof so
I can take it [ __ ] tough I feel like
the key to finding spiritual bliss is
not being a slave to the Apple iPhone
release cycle I released myself from
that years ago my skin is clear I get
eight hours of sleep at night and I feel
like I'm amazing I don't give a [ __ ]
about what high phone you're dropping
see please Tim Cook see folks whatever I
don't know you know Rihanna released her
Fenty Beauty line giving literally
everyone that's ever tried to do Beauty
a run for their money all the black
woman in the world are thank you as
someone who doesn't wear or buy makeup
like Rihanna could make me buy me oh she
has 40 skin tone shade she made such a
point of making it incredibly inclusive
all of these like makeup lines are
releasing these you know foundation
colors for dark-skinned women and it's
like well then I know everyone buys
makeup she doesn't just slap her name on
something she's like I'm gonna go 110
percent that's why I love her darker
skin women didn't have the makeup they
needed and she just provided it all so
that I can highlight Rihanna is perfect
she can do no wrong I will follow her
into a pit of fire she's just out here
making political stances and these coins
I cannot even be mad at her I want to
see the iPhone Rihanna
I want Apple twice the line of Rihanna
thumb yes apologetically black as she
should be
movie it came out and it also introduced
us to our new gay icon
Pennywise his makeup is beat to
perfection he's got that beautiful like
flowing red hair jawline the jawline the
outfits I have decided to stand the
babadook and Pennywise I'm on board I'm
on board the ship they deserve each
other
I want to know who's the top I think
Pennywise is the bottom I do sail charge
listen this 2017 everyone should be
versed and the word on the street is
that everyone wants to [ __ ] Pennywise
right because there's play by when the
white makeup runs off he's giving me a
little bit of serial killer vibe at the
same time you can get it so you [ __ ]
Pennywise in Pennywise costume if it
meant you could be with Bill scars guy I
kind of want a little bit of crown
makeup still on him you're saying if I
[ __ ] Pennywise one time I get to marry
bill skarsgård yeah yes of course
Alexander Skarsgard his older brother he
is the crown jewel of the family I'm not
gonna be the other man to the most
iconic gay relation to that relationship
so it was just announced that Selena
Gomez got a kidney transplant from her
good friend she's got her friends
donated kidneys I'm lucky when my
friends took me back I heard that the
weekend is like scheduling his
appearances around her recovery she's
pretty much goals other than Pennywise
and melody two most iconic couples of
2017 mark our words so that's this week
in pop culture
I personally am hoping Rihanna's next
step in her career is taking on Ted Cruz
next week I'm hoping that Paul Ryan will
like a porno tweet involving penny wise
in the babadook
wanna see some Michael B Jordan aka
Michael busted open anything Michael B
Jordan you'll have to laugh it up yeah
Michael Jordan Michael baby daddy
Jordan Breanna you get Irish took what a
watch